too embarrassed so so i just
i was just watching this movie through
my phone that was dying then everybody
everybody just said yeah this huge ipad
i've been first class but i'm over here
like an economy [ __ ]
just wait but i don't understand why if
you just be like hey can i get my ipad
or did you not know to ask i have
anxiety okay
wait for because i don't want them to
know know what
i don't know
i don't know i'll cut this part out
but you're the most confident anxiety
person in five
four three two one what's up everybody
welcome to an episode of the genius
brain
podcast if you've never heard of this
podcast before you must be a sad sad
person
we have a very very special guest i
actually don't know this [ __ ]
but
but to me he's like actually one of the
funniest asian comics out there i think
you
have something that a lot of people
don't have that they think that they
have
right and for me right now i'm on this
mission to find
really good like asian comics i think
there's a lot of people who
and we know like comedy is very
subjective right yes
but it doesn't mean that i'm not gonna
push people that i feel like that are
really great
and like i feel like a lot of people
need to see what you do
dude that's so nice man seriously dude
yeah i feel really good right now i'm
telling you man honestly
yeah that's because i used to uh my we
used to watch him with my friend like
you know a while ago yeah man because i
remember i
went went to the it was like we met at
the boxing match yeah and uh
i went to you at first i was like that's
david
well that's so weird because like i feel
like you as a st you're way better than
me
and the thing well i i keep on doing it
and i don't know but because like you
said it's objective but the thing is
when i met you though
um i was like hey you're david so i'm
i'm jason and then you also said your
name you're like
i'm david but they're like aggressively
and then you squeeze my hand i was like
why are you gonna do that that's just
how i was like
you can just say my first name you son
of a [ __ ] and keep it down right oh my
god because it's covered and people know
i mean
people are gonna cancel myself so i
actually met jason because when people
squeeze the hold on
well when people squeeze your hands yeah
when people squeeze your hand they want
you to know they're in the room i'm like
[ __ ] i know you're in the room
no dude i was going to actually tickle
the middle of your palm with my index
i'm going to let you know i was like
april you're kind of cute
so first of all this is like the
jankiest promotion i've ever been to in
my life
so you know like celebrity boxing is
really big this is in the middle of
covent by the way
[ __ ] in the
in this room i triple messed up just in
case but
this was that so we you guys already
know about christino sosa
or chris sosa and pat they've been on
this podcast well they were the
headliners and they were gonna box each
other because they're both stand-up
comics but they both have boxing
experience
yeah so jason was also a part of this
lineup now i didn't know anything about
you right yeah
but they told me that you had bad blood
with this dude yeah that you were going
to box right and i just saw this clip of
you guys facing off and he was mad
aggressive towards you really really and
then you were just kind of like
what was going on yeah i was like yeah
what's wrong what
what was the the [ __ ] between you two
dude this is such a long thing
and um i'm gonna tell you this so
it was it was because of a joke joke
thiever he accused me of stealing jokes
okay okay can i just before you even
continue okay
and this will connect to what we say
later on i saw this dude's instagram
he is literally the hackiest
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life
so i don't know what joke you would
steal from him
yeah but like i don't know him
personally but you're trash but continue
okay
so so um but i don't want so we went to
high school together
oh really yeah so we went to army and
navy academy in carlsbad
and uh so i know of him he knows of me
and
we weren't like super friends friends
and then uh when i started doing
stand-up he was like the only two person
i know that's doing stand-up and another
person was uh
i googled taiwanese comedian okay
so then okay because i just there
weren't that many yeah yeah yeah and i
wanted
you know my you know see if there's
because i'm taiwanese yeah i was like
so anyways steven and then uh i googled
and then i was like hey man remember me
i'm
you know i'll give him rides and stuff i
would i would drive him to
arizona and it wouldn't i wouldn't wait
why would you drive to arizona
because i thought this was like you know
you got to pay your dues you just you
know because he didn't have a car
okay i could drive you and he's like hey
man i'll bring you on my wing and stuff
like that but
dude and i was close with the other you
know asian comedian
and uh long story short um ed
ed this other asian comedian i was
opening for him
okay i was he and i was like oh this is
so nice this is the best
and i did a joke and he didn't say
anything
and then two months later he's like bro
you stole my joke i was like what are
you
what are you talking about he's like oh
i have the joke in my album and i didn't
even hear that joke in an album
and uh and and yeah and then he was like
bagging steven briggs
when it was another this is another
thing about uh stephen briggs was
i was like hey man ed wanted to get into
this other club can you help
us get into this club and then stephen
was like oh no you know
you're not ready like to me and then i
was really sad because we were friends
let's die okay i was really sad i know
it's just the way he said it was so cute
i was really sad i was super sad because
i was like yeah yeah yeah we're friends
and then uh and then ed they teamed up
and then they're like bro you stole my
thing
and then it's not even steven it's not
even his joke
and this was seven years ago yeah and
then fast forward
now jose great hilarious coming he
did the fight thing put it together and
then he was like hey man do you want to
do it
i was like yeah man it'll be fun but um
and i had in the past i i did boxing
right and
i was like who would i box and he's like
me i was like oh perfect
this is gonna be a fun thing but then uh
two days later he's like bro there's
this guy he want to
really want to [ __ ] you i was like who i
was like stephen he's like steven i was
like
oh man but my pride got in the way
because i would have said no
because it's like i don't because what
was the joke that he said that you stole
okay it's super hacky because in the
beginning in the beginning i all i did
was stereotypes because in my head i was
like i want to
turn the stereotype into a positive
because there's so many asian
stereotypes that i hate
and i'm like i'm gonna do it and make it
positive but then everything
the people were laughing at me instead
of
with you i don't like the way that they
were laughing because i'm like even if i
try to turn them positive
it's still i think enabling them and
then oh
give him the okay to laugh uh but the
joke was
aside from gangnam style with the punch
line and i was like we don't have a
leader
like in america so i was like you know
uh black people got
martin luther king malcolm x and latinos
got caesar chavez who do
asians got aside from gangnam style
that's it it's like the stupidest
stupidity so it's a small joke and then
he did like
he was he said some other he was like i
think entertainers
like britney spears and some other thing
and then the punch line is also
safe from comics but i swear to god i
remember the place
like in my apartment i thought of that
one i was like dude i'm a [ __ ] but
even even
even if though that's a pretty light
joke like it's
i'm pretty sure anybody could have came
up with that joke i know it's really
similar
and i really i didn't do it like and if
you don't believe it like i can't
there's no way for you to be like oh man
like you know here's the thing though
this is the hard part that a lot of i
feel like a lot of comics are going to
have to understand
everything is on the internet now and
you're going to see a lot of crossover
jokes i've seen them multiple times
i've even had a crossover joke with uh
like one of my [ __ ] heroes and now
friends is bobby lee
yeah i used to do a joke about my dad
and this is something my dad
said to me yeah but bobby lee had it in
his stand-up set yeah i just had to take
it out because he's just known for it
but i didn't steal his joke
yes literally i could bring my dad on
this podcast he'll tell me yeah
that he he used to say to me go i
remember when i told him i wanted to be
a comic he goes
oh so you want to be a crown he said
with the red nose
and but bobby literally had this set but
that's something my dad said verbatim i
used to put it in my stand-up set
somebody told me like you're stealing
bobby's jokes and i saw it i was like
well i'm just gonna take it out right it
happens and this is the same thing when
he told me i never did it again
and then stephen seven years later
he's like this is my chance now and then
i'll and i
what was that here's the thing though
was that joke really going to set his
career off like
it's such a small that's what i'm saying
but he was really angry so
so and then i don't even know why he was
so angry i'm like it's not even your
bit yeah but and i i understand that you
should protect
always protect the comics who's you know
if they're stealing then definitely
protect
but he saw the amount of anger that he
had i i was like this is
so he's saying something he's you stole
somebody else's bit that he knows
yeah not his though not his what the
[ __ ] is wrong with this guy yeah so he
was that angry and then
yeah and then we i mean it's not even
that big of a joke though
okay but i failed hey
let's talk about this [ __ ] though listen
i didn't know jason right
this [ __ ] has a shirt off i'm
talking about this dude is ripped as
[ __ ]
like it's it's disgusting how buffy is
right no cardio
like straight up buff as [ __ ] so i'm
like dude
he's about the latest he's about to lay
something on this [ __ ] right
this guy gets in the [ __ ] ring and
i'm like guy what's going on here
what are you doing what are you first of
all both of you were
inexperienced so like watching youtube
box was a little weird
the biggest difference between you and
and that other dude was he wanted to
hurt you you know for sure you didn't
want to hurt him
yeah and that's where a lot of people
fail in these matches your attitude
about what you go into that range
very [ __ ] important if you have no
malicious intent that purge is gonna
knock your head off oh for sure
and he wanted to [ __ ] kill you he did
he would if he had a knife he would have
used it he would have taken his life
it was bloodsported he broke a pill in
his shorts and he threw it in your eye
dude yes
yes i was like i can't see this is why i
lost no no but uh
i think i thought about for two like two
weeks i was really sad
i was like dude i was really sad but
um the reason why i think i didn't win
is because i didn't like like you said
my intent and i didn't want it bad
enough
well you had to want to hurt him you
didn't you weren't throwing like you
wanted to hurt him yeah he was throwing
but i was
really tired though i was really tired
why are you buffing for dude what the
[ __ ] is all that for
dude my insides are messed up it's
nice on the outside but it's like i look
like you on the inside
that's what it is yes you got you
probably got way better cardio than i
did
no for real i mean okay like i was so
like i didn't know who he was but i felt
like he failed every asian person on
earth i was really sad
i was pissed because his girlfriend said
a racist racist ass comment
she was like did you hear what she said
she was like sending back to the [ __ ]
factory
oh man and that [ __ ] had my blood
boiling and i'm like bro
you better [ __ ] knock the white
supremacy out of this [ __ ]
and so when that happened too there's a
thing that pissed me off too this is
supposed to be a friendly boxing match
yeah it's not i mean i really wanted to
enjoy it
okay i swear to god i swear to god
because i was like it's all comics it's
a goofy time
it wasn't trying to kill you yeah man
and i didn't have a good time
i wanted to have a good time so
the he's he's knocked down on the ropes
sitting down right yeah
and that's a normal decent human being
especially because this is like an
exhibition match
no knockouts no nothing he's clearly
done and he
cracks him with a a hook and another
hook while he's
sitting on the ropes the whole crowd
gets pissed at this full but it's okay
though because it's boxing like what are
you not gonna it's kind of like mma
but it's not okay though because in
boxing you don't do that he was also
sucking you at the back of the head
yeah so there was a lot of dirty [ __ ]
that he was that's why people were
booing him
yeah because we were pissed we're like
yo what are you doing man this is
supposed to be a comic boxing thing yeah
and he started
knocking you upside at the back of your
head when you were done boxing yeah you
don't do that in boxing
period in the story so like for that it
was just really weird mike tyson did
some stuff
oh well mike tyson's a little different
yeah this is this
i mean like tyson dmt tyson over here oh
shout outs to mike tyson though like i i
i mean he's a little
he's he's my hero yeah a little crazy
though it's a little different yeah a
little bit
a little bit different i wish i want you
to run back that fight
so bad but the thing is i will want to
too but i don't want it bad enough
like i'll do it do what i mean but i'm
going to get tired and i'll be like okay
let's go home guys
dude i was i started i started booing
him in the middle of the match
i was like boom i was like what that's
so sad because i used to watching
youtube
man that's crazy so you knew what bought
me from youtube from back in the day
yes yes uh and i remember my friend who
would send each other
like your clips and stuff that's crazy
yeah and i never saw you like in person
anyway so i was like oh man
that's just nuts man like when i when i
look back and i see other people like
for you right like you saw me but i'm
watching your stand-up now yeah you know
which is such an
odd thing to see why is that because
it's just like you don't
i don't ever think that somebody that
watches me is gonna go into
entertainment too i just feel like i'm
their like relief for their nine-to-five
job
but there's other people who get into
like the space and they start honing
their craft and you see people come up
and it's pretty wild
you know because you've been how long
have you been doing stand up for eight
years that's a long [ __ ] time yeah
but i i lied a lot
that's good okay because if you don't
lie then then people be like oh he's
green
we don't have to pay him and stuff like
that so in the beginning i lied a lot
but now i just say
i just say it and then i was like [ __ ]
it so wait so are you doing a stand-up
full-time
yeah damn dude my um my best year i'm
proud of this
um i made a hundred a hundred thousand
that's a [ __ ] ton dude yeah that's
really [ __ ] good yeah but um
this year unemployment 40 it's
i mean it's it's [ __ ] pandemic no but
it was it
my wife pays for most of the stuff okay
that's right
right now but hey she believes in you
that's dope i know but
but i do it full time that's amazing you
know what in the beginning because
in the world right now if you're not
like famous if you don't have a
following like people come pay money to
see you
uh the most money that you could make is
either on cruise ships or colleges
and i just did that for like two three
years that's amazing yeah and then
i'm in the beginning i'm like if i could
just do colleges
i've made it because even if i fail as a
stand-up i could still make money
right it's a little your asian spirit
comes out a little bit right there
yeah yeah so i was happy about that but
then 35 shows in
i was like i'm gonna kill myself i've
performed on a fireplace before
like just a fire i was in a college
campus and there was a fireplace and
then they're like hey what's your name
and i was like jason and then
everybody's eating like pizza and people
are going to class
i've done that too yeah dude it's
demoralizing yeah that and cruise ships
i did and i was really excited for
cruise ships too and then
i wanted to you know jump jump overboard
after like
after like months of it but um but yeah
now i just
i don't know um but the really fun shows
they don't really
yeah i mean it's a different because
it's still a business at the end of the
day but you could do that though
but you you were talking about that well
i mean we were talking about off podcast
it's like
you know i had to go through a
realization of like stand up is
something that i enjoy but i don't know
if i have the heart to
right now anyways to pursue it 100
because
you know things that i want to do i want
to be very very passionate about because
stand-up's hard what are you passionate
about now making
food businesses like but you have it you
have some yeah but we're on we're on
we're we just started we're at the baby
party right now
so we have a franchise that opened up
in for you guys who don't know it's june
b matcha we have one that opened up in
richardson texas
one in jersey we have one out in uh
irvine
i mean not irvine um ucla this episode
is brought to you by
bluetooth my friends fellas i know there
are some of you guys out there that
don't feel like a stallion in the
bedroom
well no more because guess what floppy
man you don't have to be ashamed of it
it's all good because
listen i got the solution for you and
that solution
is bluetooth baby no shame in your game
why must there be shame around things
that we need help with
your captain wants to salute you matey
and your matey wants you to swab that
dick
so let's get that motion back in the
ocean no jokes
well realsies blue chew is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost blue chews tablets
help men
achieve harder slash stronger erections
to combat
all forms of eed blue chew is an online
prescription service so no visits to the
doctor and
all the awkward conversations and no
waiting at line in the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet
package sun how dope is that listen
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code brain at
checkout just pay
five dollars for shipping that's
bluechew.com promo code brain to receive
your
first month free and we thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this podcast
in westwood we have one in uh roland
heights
and then we have one we have a few more
that are probably going to open or two
more in texas and i think two more in
jersey
and then a few other people and then uh
another potential opening right now
but unless we just started with this and
then i have a soft-serve place that i'm
probably going to open up next year
so i mean we're working you so many
things though
yeah i mean but but how do you because i
was thinking about that like you have
so many businesses but you trust the
people who run your stuff because
i work with these people for a very long
time all of them but you have so many
businesses though
it's all same people oh yeah i like the
texas
the circles circle these are franchisees
though they they all they franchise
their clothes
so we run with the very tight circle
like we know each other we actually have
the same accountant
so everything is the same okay so like
i've i've curated relationships with
it's bart and joe and all them we've
curated our relationship together for
the past 12 years oh
we we we [ __ ] with each other heavy
sorry if i'm
because your followers probably already
know but i was just curious
oh no no no i mean we could talk i mean
it's just a podcast so they they'll hear
the stories over multiple times
but um yeah i mean for for me like i
always want to
just do stuff that always makes me happy
so because food was the big thing like
sold the show to thrills it was a food
show i was on a netflix show uh
called the best leftovers ever and i'm
still pursuing food right now because as
of right now this is something that i
care about
and i feel like we'll stand up like i
just come back to it you know and i'm
always writing 24 [ __ ] seven so it
doesn't matter
yeah it might be a little dated like i
do a kobe joke
ten years later i'm like what the [ __ ]
bro it's ebola again dude be quiet
yeah you know but you know who knows
yeah but that the earlier you were just
talking about how
like you you would write every single
day but do you just you either put it on
the pod
i doubt that was really surprising to me
that you put it you write every day but
you don't go and do it just because you
are passionate about the other things
yeah it's just
that's like a habit that's like oh is it
just to train your like
like comedy chops you do it since you're
like 16 years old you're gonna just
could do it
that's just what it is so if i think of
something really funny
i'm gonna write it down it might go into
a script yeah it might go into
i don't know if i do a vlog one day
again it might go into something else
but for me just to think of something
funny and then not write it down
it feels weird like i have to write it
down and sometimes like i'll
like i on a podcast i talked about this
one story i wasn't going to put into a
stand-up comedy bit but i just told it
on the podcast instead
which i regret now it was really funny
it was literally just this moment where
i realized
as a kid like my two my best friends
were [ __ ] like what
i didn't realize this i was in the car
and i had this [ __ ] revelation moment
i was like
yo two of my elementary best friends
were actually mentally challenged and i
had no idea oh
so when i go back home i'm going to
check my [ __ ] pictures to see if i
was in the in the [ __ ] special class
also with hardest yes
i remember how how long or short my bus
was
i'm like oh [ __ ] well i actually that's
stupid but i told it on the podcast but
that was supposed to be a standard bit
but i just kind of put it on the podcast
you know but you know like there's it's
just the muscle that i never want to
forget i'll be doing this till the day i
die even if i don't do podcasts anymore
even if i don't do stand up i'm always
gonna just write jokes because number
one it makes me happy
yeah and it's something that i've always
been doing it's also cool too
like let's say i just want to do an open
mic i'll just go do an open mic
yeah and then see what happens i could
be 70 years old i'll do a [ __ ] open
mic who cares what's your schedule like
because you have the businesses then you
got the po but i have a lot of great
partners so we all do things in tandem
so in the morning
how i work morning i don't work for [ __ ]
nighttime is when i work
because uh in the daytime is when i want
to be out
i want to go bike eat stuff eat [ __ ]
kick box do all that other stuff you
know [ __ ] wave at small children
i want to do i want to do all that [ __ ]
and then that's where i get canceled
they're going to take that [ __ ] bit
and i'm done
but i do that and then when it hits
night time is when i'm on the computer
working because it's dark anyway so i'll
just stay in this room
yeah do you wait for um your wife
no fiance fiance to go to sleep and then
you
well it usually starts when she's away
but she goes to sleep really early so
i'm like up till like three or four a.m
but like i prefer to have my day time
where i could do what i want and then
i'll just work my ass off at night
and then kind of do it that way i mean
it's just it's work life balance and i
just i figured out a way to do it
because i always told myself work super
hard in the morning just
you know right when the sun's about to
go down you'll have enough time but it's
like i make my own schedule
[ __ ] do your [ __ ] the other way
around yeah like i'm an insomniac
yeah so who cares like you're gonna stay
up either way so just work yeah when
people say like oh
because my dad always wanted me to like
get up early
and then i always had that in my mind so
um
i used to work for my dad and he has a
manufacturing
business okay and uh i i always want to
go into work first
and then i'll go to like china with him
and um
[Music]
i remember always being in the office
first but i like being up at night so
i'm always getting like and i'm not
i don't sleep well and i'm oh and in the
car he could sleep
anyway he's the type of guy that was
could sleep anywhere
and he's always like he's always like
why are you why are you sleeping in the
car you're so lazy
yeah i'm like no dude it's just that you
could sleep but you know
but uh but yeah he's always like giving
me [ __ ] if i sleep
i have to wake up before six or else i'm
like a piece of [ __ ] but you said you
were you were what
you were were you in the military or no
a military boarding school
it's called army navy academy when i
came here when i was 15
uh i went to army navy well you were 15
from taiwan yeah i've been
from taiwan oh [ __ ] dude your [ __ ]
english is on point bro i know that's
real good dude
thank you that's tight i practiced
that's dope yeah but there's that this
is another thing like
i feel like if you speak english a
little more fluently
i only have a slight accent people would
just oh he's probably asian american and
he's not like
you know authentics because most people
don't give a [ __ ] enough to do it dude
like you're like because i wanted people
to like me i don't want people to keep
on making fun of my accent
but i feel like some people who does
have the accent people oh but he's the
authentic one
yeah yeah but it's like no dude i'm also
authentic yeah you're like taiwanese as
[ __ ] then
i but this that's the thing i also been
here 15 years so it's like oh yeah i
forgot a lot of
i forgot so i'm like nothing as [ __ ] i
went to taiwan like a few years back
and taiwan's [ __ ] street food the
food's so good dude what the [ __ ] like
the street food is amazing i went to
like the fancy restaurants yeah i was
like
give me the [ __ ] out of here get me back
to the the [ __ ] street food [ __ ] yeah
it's so good yes and they're so cheap
too and nobody [ __ ]
by the way i found out the worst way
possible that when when you're getting
like
breakfast like street food yeah like get
it in the morning later on it's
terrible so i got it like oh yeah i went
to the safe i wanted the same food again
yeah
and i went back and they're on clothes
and they gave it was like the worst [ __ ]
i've ever had i'm like okay
and they sold it to me anyways those
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they knew what they
were doing it's got to be hot in the
morning
yeah but we can't we can't even uh you
can't even visit taiwan right now right
because uh
no because of the yeah i mean there's
the two i'm talking
i'm telling you i was just talking about
that but i was gonna um i was going to
go in july but then now there there were
zero cases for like months
but then now there's more there's like
they have a spike of 12.
they're very particular everybody's
leaving now yeah but you went to
boarding school right
yeah without yeah so i went to boeing
school and um
yeah i went there for two and a half
years so i went and then um
i this is another thing i didn't live
with my i just this is just
i just thought of this recently i didn't
live with my parents until fifth grade
because i lived with my grandparents and
then because now i'm giving my parents
[ __ ] because i will call them i'll be
like i i
talked to my dad recently i was like
remember that i didn't end up with you
guys till fifth grade why is this
wait why why why no i know were just
really busy working
they [ __ ] hated you bro i'm sorry
that's why i did they [ __ ] hate it
they were hoping that you would forget
about them and you would be grandma and
grandpa your
parents yeah that's what it was uh yeah
so but then after i went to the
winter boarding school and i was really
excited because my dad
he get like every you know asian parents
like he would just
you know spank me all the time and uh i
ran away from home twice
uh and then i came back i lived in a pc
pc bank yeah for like those 24 hour
[ __ ]
pc yeah they knew me because i would
like have my
go and then um and then they knew me and
then i was like can you stay here please
and they're like yeah
and then my grandma found me wait did
you did you ever run away and then get
your [ __ ] ass beat when you came
back of course my dad was beating my ass
and my dad
and my mom's like yeah i thought you
said you weren't going to
yeah it's the worst thing it's like when
you run away and you come back to asian
household it's like
i need these people for survival but i'm
about to get [ __ ] up
yeah i would i would be waiting outside
just kind of prepping my mind like
oh just to get it [ __ ] my ass up yeah it
might no let me tell you this [ __ ] so my
dad one time
i used to this was like an old stand a
bit so i'll just say but that was like
this
true [ __ ] story my my brother was
like the
the golden child right every my parents
[ __ ] love this dude they hated my
guts understandably so i wasn't the best
kid
so i remember watching my my dad and my
brother get into a fight
and my dad would get hurt by the things
that my brother would say
my brother would say terrible [ __ ] you
go like you know what if you put your
hands on me don't ever [ __ ] call me
your son
and i remember watching that moment and
my dad
went to the couch laid down and he
started crying
it was [ __ ] what then i was like you
can't do that i know
let me tell you yeah i was [ __ ]
pissed because
there's no way it works i literally told
my dad something very similar i was like
you put your [ __ ] hands on me you'll
never see me again
i walk outside the door he closes it
shut i heard 17 locks
i didn't even know we had that many
locks
and i sat out there i was like what the
[ __ ]
like this guy legit he didn't even blink
twice
and then in the most sarcastic way
possible but by the way i did this
during winter
yeah and i'm sitting standing out there
it's raining in sacramento i'm like what
have i done
and i remember i just knocked on the
door he was like i thought you're gonna
start a new life
what are you doing here and watching my
dad cry because my brother was like
don't ever hit me again and
he started bawling i'm like oh i'm [ __ ]
in this family
[ __ ] this dude he didn't care dude but
so that that's the type of treatment my
brother would get he was the golden
child yeah so when my brother said he
was gonna leave i thought his my dad
thought his whole world was falling
apart but when i [ __ ] left he was on
the adoption he was like getting on the
adoption list looking for a new son
that's just crazy i didn't know that i
that was the first time i realized i was
like
he has a favorite yeah i mean i should
have known he was beating my ass but
still
but he really had a favorite yeah but
now how's the relationship
well i make more money than my brother
so you know i'm the yeah i'm the golden
child
did you did you see the transition i saw
the transition when
like i finally got my mom to admit i was
like
what you made them admit i was like
listen what
you that's all messed up i was like you
liked my brother
way more than you liked me she goes but
he said they print now
like yo hearing them admit hurt
it hurts so much more than i expected i
was like yo man like i knew it
but they hear it from her [ __ ] mouth
i was like yo [ __ ]
stop in the blow like don't don't just
[ __ ] outward say this [ __ ]
he's a different now like he's different
no but but
it's also positive because he also she
also likes you now yeah well she likes
me now because i buy her things
you know it's a little different yeah
you got a virus but she
we we developed a really great
relationship because i also learned a
lot about my mistakes and kind of
i wasn't very empathetic towards them
right they weren't empathetic towards me
i wasn't empathetic towards them
i know what was the thing that you and
your brother like what was the
difference that
what were you he was the firstborn
that's where all your love goes
if you're if you're a second born child
out there just know you're not [ __ ]
they did everything they could with the
first one they're tired by the time you
come around like nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you
and so that's why if dude i [ __ ] you
[ __ ] not yeah you look at
this is how i also do when you look at
our kids photos right we had these
albums at home of all of our children's
photos yeah my brother's six books this
thick mine this big one
one book oh man and it's just like
blurry pictures of me
yeah they're all blurry like suddenly my
dad's vision was really poor
yeah i was like yo what the [ __ ] your
mom drew drew
which is a page of you it's on crayon 15
years old
she's like when did i draw this she goes
oh actually i drew it of you because i
didn't have anything
else yeah and i'm [ __ ] fat and ugly
as [ __ ]
she tries a racist draw to me but i have
slanted eyes but
yeah but like my parents always played
favorites and i didn't realize this
until later on
and you see like all these like small
little instances of it but we we hatched
our [ __ ] out now so we're good
you know because what for you like so
you live with your your uh
grandparents when you're younger and the
fifth grade decide to take you back
before we continue this podcast my brain
farts we are brought to you by
purple i can't tell you how much i love
my purple mattress because it has been
giving me some of the best sleeps of my
life gangster style
start loving yourself by respecting your
rest with a purple mattress before my
purple mattress i was sleeping on a
quilted bag
of pain is that you waking up wondering
why your spine has gone through trials
and tribulations and disrespect shame on
you
what'd that back do to you bless
yourself with a purple mattress
purple's technology in their products
keeps me cool
supports my back sides hips necks and
shoulders
it gives me the love i've always needed
you won't regret it and guess what
free shipping and return so what you're
waiting for you
silly silly butt farts purple really is
comfort for an uncomfortable world
and right now you'll get 10 off any
order of 200 or more go to purple.com
slash gb10 and use promo code gb10
that's purple.com
gb10 promo code gb10 for 10 off any
order of 200
or more purple.com gb10 promo code
gb10 terms apply what what no
in fifth grade so i lived with them for
like two years and then
they're like oh you could you know
because my friend wanted to uh
they were gonna go to america for the
first time yeah and then they're like oh
you should
there you should go too and he's the
military and it was my best friend i was
like dude [ __ ] oh man i want to go
yeah my friend and then yeah and then i
went and i was really happy because
i get to be free wait when you so when
you went to uh board what is boarding
school exactly like what is because i
know boarding school is people who are
[ __ ] up kids
go there um i think a lot a lot of them
or
just their parents you know wanted a
private time
okay just thought some alone time yeah
yeah yeah um
and uh well my mom is really independent
i think they
i really think my my mom and dad is like
um the complete opposite
it just they did it because like it's
the social thing like we should have a
kid yeah we should have a kid
and then because i remember one time i
was telling my mom i was like mom
um she's like uh actually
to be honest with you i didn't want kids
like she told me there's multiple things
what
what's with our [ __ ] up parents
telling us these truths that we don't
need to know yeah
yeah so yeah she shows she's like yeah
well
uh i didn't want kids and then i was
like a sad
and then i'm sad a lot yeah i thought
your whole life
you're just what is that how is that and
then uh
and then she's like but don't worry like
after a year i started to love you i was
like oh that's really nice
whole year she just looked at you
yeah no but then yeah so then eighth
grade
i i went to boeing school so i was
really happy because i was free and then
that's when i first cause i um
my wife's career i have a wife she's
korean and
that's i really got in with the koreans
in the culture because
i didn't um i was getting bullied
and then i didn't know the korean
culture and one in this one class
he was like held back probably like
three or four years just tight
and i was like because i was the worst
student always like i was you know
roasting a teacher
in my broken broken dog i would kill
myself if i was a teacher getting
roasted by a kid who couldn't speak
english
this [ __ ] thick taiwanese mandarin
accent i'd be so [ __ ] pissed
yeah yeah so i was roasting the teacher
and then
the korean guy uh he's like hey shut the
[ __ ] up
and then and i didn't know did he have a
broke korean accent too
yeah yeah he was you shot a [ __ ] up okay
it's like dude this [ __ ] special bus
ass class right now
you know is he just like what's going on
we're the only two asians like god damn
it yeah yeah
um and then he like you know people
would like their lips they're like
like really pissed and i thought i
didn't know that
korean people fight like that i didn't
know this so i was like you shut the
[ __ ] up you know what i mean you the
square head like i was just you know
tell him stupid and then he's like after
okay he's like okay after
let's go fight and i was like okay let's
go fight i didn't think he he
sorry okay this dude
broke in english too broken english you
just didn't understand what he was
saying no he said let's go fight
i was like okay let's go fight like oh
you want to go eat you should they just
went outside
and all of a sudden he gave you a
knuckle sandwich yeah yeah
yeah but he said let's go fight and then
he beat my ass
and then uh he'd be my and i was really
sad too you would have been really
really angry with him because he would
have been so because he was beating my
ass and then i was like
okay stop i'm sorry i didn't want it
enough
but the thing is i would do it it's the
story of your life dude
you like call this full out of this
bluff it's like i'm a kiki you ass
and you're like well [ __ ] do it then
guy i
wish i was in that classroom listening
to you [ __ ] fobs fight each other
i think i would have died laughing oh
yeah you're going to punch me in the
head [ __ ] square face
this guy's like oh you want to die okay
yeah i'm like
this is [ __ ] up asian drama yeah so
that's exactly
yeah and then that's uh that's pretty
much what it is and i i was uh
and then i uh and after i just became
friends with
all the koreans and they were um the
people still made fun of me and stuff
like that but
just less and then um when so when you
came to
the united states did your did you
already know some english stuff yeah
because we have english classes and i
was always
everybody does it better outside from
the u.s dude because everybody's
multilingual except for a [ __ ]
american oh yeah
yeah yeah but americans they do the
spanish thing yeah very poorly very
poorly yeah
yeah so you already knew like your
english was it was okay before you came
here yeah because i'm really good with
tones
okay and then so um i will always
i could act like i could speak well
but yeah but my writing is really that's
where it shows
like almost you've been lying to us this
whole time yes
that's like the only thing i could talk
to people but then like all the writing
all the classes i failed i felt i don't
even know how to graduate
so you said you got bullied in school
yeah everybody did what do you mean yeah
well
not everybody but yeah i got bullied a
lot but i know certain people that just
never did
what i mean well i mean i don't know
what school you went to but in my school
they're the bigger stronger better you
are oh yeah
people were just yeah yeah i forgot the
bullies
yeah and the big guys the bullies got
bullied at home when their parents want
to feed him and [ __ ] like that
if i'm gonna grow up in a broken home
that's like their thing yeah that was
probably a little too real for some
people out there
like hey bro man probably yeah so you
got
so you went to boarding school and then
you obviously didn't do stand-up right
after what did you
do in between that uh so i went to
community college uh in miramar in san
diego
and then uh and then after that i did
i worked at bluefin which is a sushi
restaurant and i worked at radio shack
yeah and then i worked with my dad and
then that's when i got
even sadder because of course i was like
i don't want to do this
and then so i just did um work for my
dad and also do stand up and then
what made you want to go in the stand up
out of nowhere like i mean what was it
something that you've always
enjoyed or was it just like oh [ __ ] i
want to do stand-up oh no i always
watched like stand-up starting ninth
grade somebody showed me russell peters
and oh yeah yeah yeah and kevin hart and
i like them
and then i never thought about doing it
but i was really sad
that's not the same that's like your old
stand-up specials would be
i'm so sad so so though this is the
[ __ ] frown face
and it's just your face on it yeah uh
but yeah that was that and then i did i
wanted to do three things i wanted to
i was like if i die what would i do so i
would do
stand up and i'll get my motorcycle
license and then
um do white rod water rafting
i know those are like three like stupid
things but i really wanted to do those
things
that's crazy like if i diet those are
the three things not
nice so do you ride a motorcycle right
now no what the [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing what the
[ __ ] are you talking about have you got
a white water rafter yet
no okay then you [ __ ] get to this you
could do this tomorrow
no okay but the thing is your goals are
so [ __ ] low just
i don't know but i know i told you i was
sad
how many times do i gotta say it 37
hours it'll be somebody's like can he
stop saying he's sad
we get it the first time he said that we
heard it you're [ __ ] i was born with
the curse that is that is your [ __ ]
special dude
yeah and then that's why so i got the
written test passed
on the on the motorcycles and then uh
and i
did an open mic and i was like oh man i
love this so i just kept doing it and i
was working and then doing stand up so i
was
i just didn't oh that must be so mad at
you guys
i want to ride a motorcycle white water
rafting yeah i would have beat your ass
the worst thing
i would literally beat the [ __ ] out of
you yes i think i asked you what your
[ __ ] life goals were not a [ __ ]
to-do list yeah
like what do you want to make of
yourself you son of a [ __ ] yeah that's
your parents supporter of you i still
apologize to them
like they're not they're they're
supportive kind of but not really
like my dad will still be like hey you
know you could also
focus on something else of course yeah
you know like it's not never too late to
you could also just work at a bank and
see i don't i don't think that's the
case for what you do though like there's
a reason why you've gotten
so much better is because this is what
you do well i i love it so much anyways
like i told them when i'm 60 if i don't
you know become successful enough then
i'll just
i don't kill myself yeah there you go no
i told him because i love it too much
like
you know the social screening of being a
justice stand up and not yeah you know
being successful
uh no as successful uh people will be
like oh he's just
you know but then i love it too much
that i would sacrifice
you know people saying stuff but then i
still
i love it and then i you know do the
best i can
well that's what that's that's what i'm
saying i don't ever suggest people
do what i do right which is just go from
hobby to hobby to hobby to hobby
but my joy in life is experiencing as
much as i want
yeah and um that's just who i am right
but it worked for you
it worked for me right but i became very
obsessive in that point
but once i reach the maximum joy of
something i try to move on to something
else
not to say i won't come back to it but i
have a finite time on this earth and i'm
going to do what i want to do
where does that come from i was just
very i was sad
two sad guys it was that bad i was sad
like i just i was always i should you
not like it's a joke but i was so
serious i was always sad
like i would wake up every day you can't
say what i'm doing you're sad
hey you said i was
we need some therapy bro but yeah
i was really sad and i i can't even say
it with the straight face anymore
i just woke up sad every day because i
wasn't doing anything i wanted
and so what were you doing nothing i
would just do whatever my dad would tell
me to do
so that's exactly that's why my to-do
list you [ __ ] on my to-do list
but that was the [ __ ] that i wanted let
me tell you what let me tell you what my
life goals were it was to be a
it was to marry somebody
as i started judging you yeah dude what
the [ __ ] i'm just saying
somebody i wasn't any better i'm sorry
my goal was to get married and have a
kid
which is like a given for most people
but that was like my life goals
i remember like just waking up so
[ __ ]
miserable right because how long were
you in that period of misery like 28
years no
it was like it was like honestly it was
for like maybe
24 years yeah if it felt that long you
know
say and uh i had this moment with my dad
where he hated me doing
stand up right he [ __ ] hated it dude
they didn't come
to see my thing until like three four
years in that's my dad still hasn't seen
anything i've done it
i mean he watches me on youtube but he
hasn't come to a show i think he also
has social anxiety so he doesn't like
being around crowds
but he didn't understand because i knew
why because it's like yo i [ __ ]
came here i'm working my ass off for you
to be a [ __ ] clown for a living
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] i get it he's doing
it out of fear
yes but the thing for him he didn't
understand like
my mom had to explain to him it's like
if you wanted him to be a korean kid and
follow your rules we should have just
stayed in korea why the [ __ ] did you
bring it yeah
he's an american boy now he has american
dreams and like the american dream
isn't about making money it's about the
opportunity and choice that you have to
be what you want to be
and so i had this moment where i was
doing stand up i was doing everything
else
and i but i had to do i was like in this
really shitty ass base in my life and i
remember
this moment where my dad and i weren't
getting along
i literally sat in the middle of the
living room and i was on my knees and i
started bawling
and he was like what's wrong of course
he was calling me a [ __ ] yeah
great parenting you know but he was like
why are you so sad
right just like that dude why are you so
sad yeah i don't get it why are you so
sad but it's the pride getting in the
way yeah he's like why are you so sad
yeah it's not like you don't eat enough
fat boy you know but you say that [ __ ]
you eat all the time that's all you do
you eat every day happy people only eat
the kings only eat all time but he's
just like yelling at me
but i remember i looked at him and i was
like hey
i've been trying to do what i'm doing
fine maybe you know something that i
don't know
i'll do whatever you ask me to do oh you
say that yeah i said man
anything you want me to do i'll live my
life by your standard so that he could
be happy yeah and i was like let's see
if this
works so i how old were you then this
was it was like
a couple years before i left to l.a so
22. 22 is 20. no 24 run 23 24.
so it was like i was in community
college
yeah aced all my [ __ ] [ __ ] i was
doing really well in school
yeah i did all this stuff and every time
i got an a yeah it didn't mean [ __ ] to
me i was like how come this grade you
told me that if i
if i show myself that i can accomplish
something like through my grades i would
feel good about this
whether it got an a b c d whatever it
didn't [ __ ] matter
it all didn't matter right and i was
like i can't live my life by his
standards i have to still search for
what i want to do
and so what happened was that um i
started doing youtube
on the side i was a youth minister i
worked at the men's warehouse
i helped my parents store on the side i
was a full-time [ __ ] student
and i but one thing had to go it was
stand-up i had to let go step oh
so i did youtube yeah i said i could
make
these funny little jokes and bits on
youtube and then i did that one ucla
video it
popped off and i was like [ __ ] school
yeah
i remember i was in class and i had a
midterm that was there and it was in
this blue book
and i literally took my my [ __ ]
sharpie i think it was a highlighter
actually
i put a [ __ ] smiley face in it i
folded it and i turned it in right when
the test started and i never came back
oh man and i dropped out wow yeah and i
went to my dad and i was like hey
uh i did it for you for a little bit
yeah i was like i tried it doesn't work
yeah
i'm gonna be a stand-up comic i'm gonna
leave like wow
and then i moved in with my cousin who's
my my manager now
i [ __ ] was broke his [ __ ] had no
[ __ ] money sold
everything that i had and then my dad in
the most asian way doesn't support me
but he buys me
a uh a dslr for my youtube
channel that's so nice and so he
explains it and he gave it to me i was
like i hope you fail
i was like thanks i take it and i stayed
in la and it's been like 11 years now
oh man were you scared though no i
wasn't scared
you weren't scared because you were like
well this is i love this i was in rock
bottom what the [ __ ] am i scared of yeah
same same that's how you know what the
anything else at this point
i got to go up so i was to the point
it's like
who the [ __ ] cares if i'm poor yeah as
long as i'm happy doing what i'm doing
yeah what you want to do the to-do list
exactly you have your but your to-do
list is more like you have more
i added something i was like yeah
stand-up comic yeah yeah
and so and i was already pursuing it uh
except for that one small gap where i
was doing
all this work and [ __ ] yeah and i missed
making people laugh
i missed that feeling that you get when
you can make somebody feel better by
laughter
yeah because when you're bullied and
you're a kid yeah
and you're gonna make fun of every
[ __ ] day the best way the best
thing that you can do is laugh at your
pain yeah that is medicine
yeah so if i could all the [ __ ]
stuff that i went through i was allowed
to put it on stand-up and youtube
and it made people feel better yeah it
made me feel good in return
yeah and that's what stand-up was doing
for me yes so that's why i
pursued to you know my pursuit of
happiness was that mm-hmm
yeah because i mean what else is there
right like
you're already [ __ ] sad and depressed
out of your mind so you might as well
just pursue what you have and i was like
to the point where
living in this little small apartment in
los angeles when i was doing youtube at
the time and things were popping i
wasn't making any money
i literally zero dollars and so i had
this
desk i bought from walmart my editing
computer and my dslr and i stayed in
that room every [ __ ] week
writing new vlogs every time wow and i
did that for like three years
constantly non-stop not going anywhere
not seeing friends no vacation no
[ __ ] nothing
and so but that's when all these
opportunities started coming and it
started
it things started rolling for me but you
write those vlogs and you put it up
every day though it was like uh once or
twice a week and so
but it was hard because it's like you're
trying to write these you're trying to
write a new bit every [ __ ] week like
three years
i did that for [ __ ] three four years
oh my god people don't know how hard
that is
it's impossible i'm wearing a new
[ __ ] set every [ __ ] week releasing
it
for [ __ ] four years straight was that
when you have a following already
it was i had a small following oh okay
and that yeah but that's still
so crazy to do it's it was so hard and
then i snapped i was like
[ __ ] i got it what am i doing i'm fat as
[ __ ] i'm miserable as [ __ ]
and then i i quit youtube for a little
bit and i came back
yeah but it'd be crazy too because
[ __ ] i lost like half my following
after i left
they're like we'll wait for you and then
i came back they're like psych
who the [ __ ] are you gonna do yeah yeah
and then you know now we do the podcast
which is kind of crazy man yeah but what
what uh
right now you do the pockets because you
just want to do you just want to do the
podcast you don't want to do the
other thing anymore that you write like
every two yeah i i
i did because it's not the same thing
yeah it's definitely not the same you
know
but podcasting too became what i was
doing with the vlog just longer
so it's like i'll maybe sometimes i'll
have a specific subject and then i can
elaborate these thoughts on
our format rather than just five minutes
yeah
and so when you when you when you uh
text me
you're like hey come you know just be
yourself just be
funny and i was like [ __ ] what if i'm
not funny then you're [ __ ] bro
what cuz i've been gassing you up this
whole podcast and they're like dude this
guy's not funny at all i know
oh man i did no but uh
but is it because i watched a couple of
them you when i saw uh
you patrick and nick you guys are like
killing the whole thing
right you killing it yeah yeah this is
how we talk all the time
you know and for that too it's just like
i failed
no no you're fine dude i don't know i've
helped
you start [ __ ] whipping yourself and
[ __ ] yeah yeah no man this is good
though
because i i feel like and i was telling
this too uh and
once again comedy is very subjective but
i i do
have this it's not a responsibility like
i'm a [ __ ] superhero but but why now
oh sorry because i you say sorry oh
because i have this platform where i can
bring people on and people can get to
know you
before if let's say i just did a vlog
and i brought you in who the [ __ ] cares
but here you could talk about your story
you could talk about where you're from
and people can really get to know you
and if they [ __ ] with you
they'll they'll carry on you can do your
own [ __ ] special or whatever that it
is
i should have prepared some more stories
i didn't want to but
brings out his [ __ ] notepad in the
middle of the podcast i wanted to tell
everybody this yeah no but this is like
always it's it's something that i always
enjoy it's like finding people that i
really [ __ ] with right
and if you're did you always do that
because you know asian not
i mean i don't know but in the comedy
stand-up comedy like
we don't help each other and it's not
because we don't want to even if we do
want to
we don't have the power to do it yeah i
mean
if i did i would love to do it i mean
for me
like and i did do something i'm not
somebody who
pushes people just because just because
yeah i i do it because i thoroughly
enjoy it it doesn't matter what you
[ __ ] are
yeah for as of right now people are
giving me examples of like asian people
in entertainment
they [ __ ] with and i don't like them and
i'm like why yeah
they suck yeah so for me it's like well
if i'm gonna sit there and be mr judgey
then why don't you put on people that
you really like right so
one day i was just like oh i saw this
dude uh pat said you were really funny
yeah i'm like
oh cool let me look up some of his clips
and i was cracking up watching a couple
of your sets
and now i have you on this podcast
because i want you to be
i want people to know who you it just
takes a little bit of opportunity for
people to see the right people
that's it so sometimes when people
there's you know asian people the asian
comics aren't as funny as other people
because you haven't seen the right ones
and some of the some of the ones that
are up there are getting more shine than
other people because they feel like
there's not enough space for all these
asian comics we just started
you know yeah so so for me like it's
like okay if i find jason funny why
don't i bring him on the phone you
didn't have to
you did uh yeah it's just um because i
was just curious about
why uh put on people you could have done
another you know another type of podcast
you could have
done you know like um i don't know
vacuum cleaners
like you know like or whatever the thing
is yeah you don't have to be like oh i
want to help out
you know other ages that's really nice
you're the yeah
third asian person that that i know
was the first guy that beat me up and
then my wife yeah and then now it's you
you're you're the nicest so far not even
your wife
my wife beats me up consistently but uh
i have pat on too because he's a comic
you know and i thought pat was [ __ ]
funny yes so i'm like let's bring pat on
dude so i did a show with pat recently
and um
but the thing is he doesn't he's not
getting up so i
facetimed him and i was like dude why
are you not getting up
just get get up and then i think he was
saying that maybe i
don't quote me but he was saying like a
little bit of pride and a little bit of
like
maybe he's scared if it doesn't work but
the thing is i was on a show with him
and i never seen his full set
i bombed and then i watched him and
it was a hard show and then he got him
it's hard to get
a crowd when they're like do i mean like
i'm not ready to laugh
that's really hard to do that and then
um yeah i wanted him to
i was like man you should do more stuff
he's he's good
yeah he's really good you know he's
cracking me the [ __ ] up and i'm thinking
right now
it's like i'm gonna just push people
that i that i believe in
right and that's really what it is
that's that's all i care about at this
point because your success doesn't take
away from mine
yeah right yeah you let's say you do
what said
the what if i can't do stand up too you
know why can't you be funny and i'd be
[ __ ] funny
you're both sad you know yeah we're both
sad
but in the beginning is because um
if you have a good set if we're both
coming and you have a good set and
you're asian
and then i don't really have that good
of a set then i'm going to be more sad
than you
because i'm like well people like him
man people don't even know us
we're sad together yeah but now but
honestly now
like i'm just the set that i would be
doing is just like
the stuff that i really care about even
though because in the beginning i just
all i cared about was making people
laugh
like laughs per minute you know but then
now um i cause if you try to make people
laugh
and don't really care about what you're
really saying
if you bomb you're like what the f what
that took me so long to do but
it's just like well what did i just do
it makes you even sadder because it's
like
one you didn't even say the thing that
you wanted to say and two nobody laughs
so why the [ __ ] are you here
yeah yeah yeah you just did five you
know sets but uh now i would just say
the things that i think is funny and
uh that i i i'm passionate about and
then if they don't laugh then [ __ ] it at
least i said the things that i wanted to
say if i die tomorrow
and that's what i that's super smart
because
i i think like when i look back at my
old stand-up i hate it so much
because you could tell that i'm so
thirsty for any type of laugh
and so i would always have like go-to
stupid gimmicky [ __ ]
because i'm afraid nobody's going to
laugh yeah but it's like what are you
doing up there then
you know yeah but then your thing was
always like
i mean most comics is always like well
you just want to make them laugh so they
could
and i started learning that from [ __ ]
dave chappelle i look at him when he
does
stand up yeah and i went to one of his
live shows and he was just talking his
[ __ ]
he's he's so good at just being himself
oh for sure
you know and i think that's like what
separates the greats from just
a regular funny guy because a lot of
comics too they'll they'll be funny
right but what there's like what's that
thing that makes a billboard a billboard
or a [ __ ] chappella chappelle
right it's because they have their own
voice and they express that to the
umpteenth degree
yeah and that's the stuff that i'm
envious about where i'm like
because even dave chappelle when he was
killing it when he was younger when we
knew him when he was first coming up
it's a different dave chappelle that we
see now
he's better now than he was then and i
was packing up his stuff
you know and so like i've probably
watched equinamity and all
all the stuff that he's seen on netflix
a million times over now because i'm
trying to figure out how he does this
like what is it about him that made me
laugh
just as much as the first time second
time and third time is because of his
way of discovery and how he does his
stuff
he does stuff that he enjoys yes you
know yes i think that's what
uh i was talking another comment
recently but they were saying the same
thing is like
you if peop he it seems like that people
are successful doing people who are
successful in stand-up is the stuff that
they say the stuff that they want to
yeah yeah it's important right and i
think too when
i think with asian comics too like dude
i saw this clip
a [ __ ] dat fan getting murdered by uh
patrice o'deal
oh oh yeah on on the show so pat talking
about that [ __ ] and we saw it off
podcast i didn't realize how bad it was
yeah it was a murder scene oh yeah they
were
killing him dude and for some reason
like it's an old clip i know what's
gonna happen but i just kept telling my
dad come back with something roast
patrice about something
talk about his diabetes say something
rest in peace
it actually killed him so i feel bad for
saying that but like say say
something but he just stood there and he
laughed and he giggled and i think
because he was in a room full of giants
oh for sure you know i i don't blame him
yeah i would have probably done the same
thing i would have cried after him been
sad too
you know that's what would have happened
yeah
i just wanted him to i mean he he won
the last comic studio he did
and so he was in a room full of people
that probably felt that he didn't
deserve to be there
and i think like his biggest problem was
that they didn't like was that he kept
on going back to the vietnamese accent
over and over and over i'm like
that you're you're the joke is funny but
you got to do something else man yeah
and that's why they picked on that
they're like are you gonna not are you
gonna just keep doing this [ __ ]
accent over and over like do something
funny
so i i genuinely feel bad for him i did
oh yeah
but yeah there's so many things because
it's like if people are eating it up but
that that's another thing like if people
think it's really funny but it's not
like uh like a thing that he really
i don't know if it's the thing that he
really wanted to say or like pro-asian
but it's also really hard back then too
to be like
right or wrong no i i mean it depends
right
because listen i i am guilty of this too
where i i mean even when i do stand up
if i'm making fun of my dad i'm gonna do
the accent that he has
yeah right but that's that's my truth
though yes it's it's what i grew up but
that's what that fan's truth is too
i think that fan's truth was it's fine
but yeah
what next right yeah so you you kind of
beat a dead horse with yeah
and so that's where it became a little
problematic too
but you know same people there's other
people who do that as well but he was
put onto a spotlight at the time
oh and like i don't think like there's
no problem with doing a [ __ ] accident
everybody does their [ __ ] accent
everybody does it yeah i feel like a lot
of the times i don't even want to
address
that i'm asian when i first get on stage
because i feel like if i
because i feel like a lot of asians do
not all of them but a lot of them do
and i just feel like oh i have to like
do this thing and then address that
that i'm asian in the middle or at the
end of my set just so to show like hey
we could we could also be funny without
saying the asian thing because
i literally have done my age and then
another comment will go on and go
oh all he's got is his you know the
immigrant
culture thing and i was like oh man that
should hurt so then i will try
another you know but it is our truth
everybody does their accent and
but you could but that's the thing too
so what you gonna [ __ ] on people laughed
about that's
my [ __ ] though i wasn't born here [ __ ]
the [ __ ] do you want from me
yeah i mean like and it makes my crowd
laugh because they could relate to it
but you know
what the thing is is so i stopped doing
the
accent thing and now when i wanted to go
back to do the accent i don't do an
accurate one
because it's all [ __ ] up yeah that was
like which one is this
yeah which asian country is i just stick
to the ones i know dude it's like i know
how my dad and my uncle speak
you know and i that's always stuck in my
[ __ ] head so that's like the best
thing and then you know all my
vietnamese friends like i grew up in the
predominantly like vietnamese areas so
yeah just the accent i
always heard right right so like i i
dated strictly only vietnamese girls
like so i
wanted to learn videos that doesn't go
away yeah so it's in the wheelhouse
all the time right my best friend is
[ __ ] uh rwandan his parents are
rewanded so i
imitate his dad all the time man so
that's just what i grew up with those
are nice tools
i didn't even think that it was a tool
to have it's just i when i tell this
story
about his dad yeah i just was coming up
it just comes up because this is how he
would talk to me yeah
like every african person knows that
[ __ ] like when you meet an old african
head
if you meet him for the first time just
know you're gonna be there for six hours
listening to his stories
yeah yeah so his dad would always i
remember when i first met his dad i
sat there he goes he starts telling me
this obscure story about how to rob a
bank
i'm like where's where's the story going
yeah he just said
let me tell you do you want to know how
to rub a bank yeah you know
i'm like you could first you go to the
bank
then you go to the bed then you take the
money then you go to the car go get into
the car
go to a tree go to it you can go to it
then you're going to bury the hole under
the tree
put the money next to the tree go
12 miles that go to another bank go to
another tree
bro i just asked you where the bathroom
is where the [ __ ] is this going
this is like the [ __ ] that i would hear
my whole life did you die did you like
that he was telling you stories
i hated it i wanted to go to the
bathroom i had to compete
i'm sitting here he's just telling me
he's obscure why do i need to know how
to rob a bank
and i just sat there for an hour
listening to the story about how to rob
a bank yeah for no [ __ ] reason and
then he was telling me stories about how
he used to get his feet beat
by his teachers until they bled if he
was late to school i'm like
what is going on here yeah but this is
like the the life i grew up with you
were just there for the accident
i was just there for the because i used
to tutor his sisters oh
so when i was in community college he
went to uh uc davis
so when i was here he would ask me if i
could tutor the younger sisters
so i just had to hear him talk all the
time and it just stuck in my head yeah
all day he would just talk to me every
day he would just go to sidewalk pizza
get some pizza come back run away from
his daughters so he would have me tutor
his daughters because he [ __ ] hated
the guys
because they were so annoying because
they were teen girls and so they would
come in and they would just jibber
jabber he goes i have to go away
he just takes you i talked to you for
three hours yeah
if you want to rob a sidewalk pizza then
you get to the cup
get the pepperoni then you go to in the
tree every day he would talk like that
[ __ ]
yeah and then you know when i used to do
that [ __ ] it would kill because it's
truth it's
it's truth that people know when you
talk to an african old head they know
what that shit's like right because i
grew up
i don't even know that was a thing yeah
bro i'm telling you like african people
are the most warm people
but they will just like talk to you
about pure nonsense for [ __ ] hours
and you just have to sit there and take
it
yeah but that sounds like it's made up
it's like made-up [ __ ] it's a true story
you know why [ __ ] it's true my best
friend
heard his dad tell the story he knows
about how his dad rambles oh
looked at me smiled and went back
upstairs left me there for hours
[ __ ] that full dude that's my best
friend too [ __ ] you dude
but yeah these are like truths that we
have so when i hear people do accents i
laugh
all the time because it reminds me of
stuff that i grew up with
and i'm okay with it i think that fan
just kind of he kind of hammed it up too
much and he didn't do other jokes
outside of it
so if it's literally a whole set where
you're doing a vietnamese accent
where's the rest of the jokes who else
do you like now that's asian
that you enjoy watching because there's
different way because you could go
because i admire a lot of asian comics
or just comics in general but
some of them don't make me belly laugh
because i love i love stupid stuff
yeah but uh but i admire a lot of the
joke writing and i
really respect that i mean i i haven't
been like i've been only recently
actively searching a lot of like
some more asian stand-up comics but like
i saw your stuff i thought you were
super [ __ ] funny
i used to love bobby lisa but he hasn't
done stand-up in a hot second yeah
and i haven't seen him stand up in a
while but bobby lee should used to crack
me the [ __ ] up because i'm a korean kid
so all the stuff that he was saying was
everything that i went through as a kid
and so i definitely had to modify my
stand up a lot because a lot of our
stories were similar oh
so have you done stand-up to a korean
like a korean-american crowd
yes how how nice is that good it's
because i don't have to explain [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's that must be so nice
yeah to do that
i i have this like weird idea of like i
this is going to be sound weird in the
beginning but uh
like sep separating the crowd like 30
asian americans but then they won't see
each other though
like yeah yeah i mean yeah white and
then
you just saw him laughing like what the
[ __ ] yeah why they love it and then
people would laugh at different places
but it's so nice to not have to explain
stuff and just i think that's the hard
part about standup too
that i learned early on was i have to
look at the crowd
yeah for sure and i just would do my
sets the same way it's like bro it's
different crowd though you gotta you
gotta make modifications
yes that's how i bombed so much in the
beginning
because i'm like no this killed last
time it's like bro but that was a
different crowd
yeah so you make it you can't make these
asians nobody they don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
yeah you know i'm just like making these
jokes about my parents beating me and
these white people are like well you
didn't have to take it
yeah yeah you know why is he why is he
giving his testimony up there
like somebody called the cops but you
know all the asian people are laughing
because they understood
right i was like i [ __ ] up here like i
i have to learn how to just
do crowd work a lot better uh crowd
works hard it's so hard
yeah i'm i don't think i'm as i mean i
try to do it um
try to practice more it's a skill though
like russell peter just
hella good that's like almost half a set
yes
it's crowd work yes i can't do that his
thing is like
really specific too like he knows about
the hong kong
things like this specific it isn't like
hacky things
yeah well that's why when people were
asking well how do you like it when
other people imitate these asian accents
it's like if it's accurate it's [ __ ]
funny
yes because he knew about cultural
nuance and that's what had me
dying laughing right nobody can say that
his [ __ ] cantonese hong kong accent
isn't spot on
it's better than mine yes you know i was
shocked when i heard that thing
i remember uh listening to it and crying
laughing it was the belly laugh i was
like holy [ __ ]
this dude knows everything about asian
people that that other
even other asian stand-up comics didn't
capitalize on it yeah he he was so much
better at explaining the nuance than he
was some asian people because they would
just do the accent
without the explanation it's like i have
a chinese dad
cool whatever russell peters would do
the accent and explain why it's [ __ ]
yes because he's making fun of these
inside jokes yes you know
i was impressed yeah for like different
cultures too like his own like middle
eastern culture and
yeah i think that's really um that's
really cool so
what's like your what's like the next
step for you right now uh
like what you were talking about earlier
how um like i said riding a motorcycle
going white water rafting
uh have a lot eat a lot of ice cream
yeah
i like ice cream i got a softer spot
coming up so you get that
oh yeah um i'm gonna look it up
but uh what was my thing sorry my
the thing do you know what i just want
to say this because
i'm i'm i'm not i don't think i'm dumb
okay it's a great segue go ahead i'm not
because the thing is i don't think i'm
done okay okay but i know i'm not smart
but i know i'm not um okay i'm like in
the middle
but the thing is your brain works really
fast and it's
like whoever's brain that works fast and
safe as things
it it it's intimidating really yeah
because you
i'm i get it like the thing is but then
my processing speed to go out is slower
but inside is processed you're like i
get it
dude i'm not dumb the thing is but every
friend that i do an impression of me
yeah it's a [ __ ] i swear every
and they don't know each other yeah
they'll be like here comes jason
i would and then because i know my mouth
is open a lot yeah
because i need oxygen yeah because my
nose
is probably bad for my brain i looked it
up i looked it up no breathers are
smarter
really yeah yeah i looked it up you're
[ __ ] like no no because the oxygens
will go in and there's like a cortex
zone with the twisties you go in and
then that's one of the dumbest things
i've ever heard anybody say by the way
there's that simple literally there's a
twisty
there you say cortex and they come with
twisties after that's [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] like i told you i'm not
smart but i'm also not dumb
this is what it is what uh so
but then every time it's a [ __ ] i'm
like when do i do this
they're like all the time but they don't
know each other but then they'll do the
same impression
and like i think i come off as [ __ ] i
hate it when but i'm not
when people [ __ ] imitate you it's
always like the worst qualities about
you that you don't need to say
it's like why you gotta do that bro yeah
like but when people imitate you do they
have the same
exact impression yes they do oh what oh
i didn't know that was a big [ __ ] you
you're dumb [ __ ] you you're dumb i'm
like
i say more things than that he goes you
think this way [ __ ] you you're dumb
i'm david so [ __ ] you [ __ ] you like holy
[ __ ]
i'm like hey that's dead huh bro cause i
literally told you that yesterday
you have your truths [ __ ] your truths
[ __ ] suck my nuts i'm like oh come on
like
it's gotten to the point now where
sometimes people are afraid to come on
this podcast
because they're afraid about things that
i'm gonna ask them oh [ __ ] but it's not
because like i'm an [ __ ] i'm just
curious about it yeah
you know yeah and they feel like go
ahead no they just feel like they have
to perform you have to perform
like oh i didn't know that well that's
how i felt this whole time because
i'm like [ __ ] he's hilarious and he told
me to be funny but i'm not i was a joke
no it's not dude i failed
i felt it's not a joke that'd be so
funny you just came in
and you stood up you grabbed the mic hey
guys it's not a standard
[ __ ] stand right here yeah yeah let's
just do what i said no man like this
podcast is just for people to get to
know you
oh you know you just talk about your
life you know and your thoughts and
that's really about it
you know dude there's a podcast where
literally
i've had people cry on this podcast
talking about their feelings so
this there's no there's no like pretense
to what this podcast has to be well i'm
glad
that this is almost over that but i'm
gonna go for another three hours
until you make something yeah i think
the sad thing is good enough for
everybody they're like
this guy's the saddest stand-up comic
i've ever made in my life
like he's he's sad i'm sad no but like
there's no
set for this for this whole podcast
because at the end of the day it's just
conversation that's what people like
about podcasts oh cool
it's just for people to to when i'm
driving and i'm listening to a podcast
i'm not listening to a podcast to learn
something new
i'm just there to hear conversation it's
just nice to hear sometimes
that's why i'm asking you about your
life what you're doing and that's really
about it
i hate it when people come on and they
feel like they have to perform you don't
have to perform [ __ ]
but i know that because comics when they
come on and i see a lot of them are so
good they're like you know i mean joke
jokes
i'm like man i can't you don't have to
do that well the thing is like sometimes
it's the vibe
too like if the other person is like
also
sometimes you know you just click better
than you know if it's like an
altitude comic because i've been on
podcast work because i don't know
exactly you know what in your head like
how you want it but but like
i have no i have no expectations oh
that's great oh perfect yeah that makes
me so happy but
like i'll go in podcast and then they
just want to talk about denim and i was
like okay cool like so they just want to
talk about them and then
yeah yeah there's just i have no
expectations of this like it's always
just fun
good conversation and everybody learns
stuff about like
you know your life experience just like
being born in taiwan coming here and
wanting to stand up comedy yeah that's
like
i would never expect that would be the
transition because i don't know any
taiwanese stand-up comics
like from taiwan that that do stand up
in taiwan i don't know if that's a thing
in taiwan
it just they just uh opened the first
club ever
oh for real yeah called uh two three
comedy and uh
there would have to be numbers in there
to goddamn it yeah
yeah it sounds like a kumon dude like
what the [ __ ] yeah
but now it's just uh because of covet
it's not
it's not they open up at the worst time
yeah turn it right through
it yeah but that's i mean that's what
i'm saying like so it's like that that
story is always great for somebody to
listen to
and that's really what it is people like
their personal experiences
what they go through like it's always
refreshing for me to see an asian
stand-up comic
because i don't know too many of my
asian peers that did stand up comedy
i was the only [ __ ] one and there was
somebody else that i knew that wanted to
stand up and he was terrible he never
made it anywhere
yeah [ __ ] him you know so wait why [ __ ]
it
i told the story before but long story
short but long story short that he um
he i led i left to l.a without him and
he assumed i was going to take him with
me as if he was like my
child oh i heard this yeah you know and
so he went on this whole time
and basically dissed me saying like oh
i'm funnier than you and i'm like oh
yeah
like you're not cause you're not here
like you [ __ ] suck go
back dude you're still [ __ ] pushing
tables and [ __ ]
yeah he could have been great you know
but he was one of those dudes that fell
into the asian tropes really hard
his first stand-up said i ever saw him
do and he continued to do this bit over
and over he goes
so i have a really small dick and i just
you would just hear just
and i just it made me die on the inside
so you ain't heard that bro
it hurts me so bad yeah and you're just
you're you're begging these people to
laugh at your culture yeah or that small
thing is our culture
right that's what we're probably
admitted
what was that you said our small dick
culture
is ours we should own up to it yeah we
are growers we are not showers
[ __ ] damn it yeah yeah but this is
stuff like that
earlier we were uh we were talking about
the um
having just a korean crowd and um i can
never say because i'm so close my wife
is great so it's like
there's so many things that i don't want
to talk about
um it like the the whole
culture of like the hyungs when they
they
bully you kind of but um but like the
only korean people will get and like my
father-in-law he took me to a
gingerbread for the first time oh you
saw his dick and everything did you
describe him did you have to scrub his
back
he didn't make me okay he would make me
but i would have done it
that's literally one of the funniest
things i love seeing that at ginger
banks because it makes me die laughing
every time
you see this old asian guy like this
right and then you see somebody scrub
his back yeah
yeah that's like the most demoralizing
thing i've ever seen in my life
but usually as a kid that like their
kids no it's like an eight year old boy
and then his saying is 70 years old
two old men describing each other so
gentle
yeah yeah it just makes me die laughing
yeah but there's like so many weird like
korean culture jokes that people know if
they're korean
like the young shit's the weirdest thing
dude like one of the funniest
just weirdest thing that korean people
would do like you would have hyungs
right yeah and they would
[ __ ] you up because they love you right
you would beat your ass right but if
somebody else would try to [ __ ] with you
they'll help they would
beat their ass right hey you don't
[ __ ] hit him we hit him right i'm
like
i actually kind of prefer if they
we got your back right don't get my back
i'm good
like you beat my ass every sunday this
is church what are you beating me up for
scheduled yeah it would be like that all
the time we would go to church it's like
hey man you ready for your ass whooping
it's like we're here for god what are
you doing dude yeah
but that's like weird korean culture
[ __ ] that people don't even know and i
don't know if like
i didn't i didn't i thought all asian
people had it that way but it's very
korean
it's super korean yeah with the ginger
bang thing do you ever get
competitive with another dude that is
staying in the hot tub
like longer because i did with the dad
and also with my dad
almost died just collapsing
i think my i don't know maybe my
my balls because you know when they say
like you stay
in the water too long i don't know if i
just say what you're gonna [ __ ] say
your sperm isn't as good is that what
they say
is this one of your little spiral coily
things in your head type of thing or
something
this is something this is real [ __ ] this
is so if you
be in the hot tub like high temperature
for longer or your balls get too hot and
they they drop too
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well your sperm
if you always do that then your sperm
would just be like well it's too
hot now so do you have it in a hot plate
how long are you in there
because i did it a lot i did it a lot
i'll go to like
wii spa or i spot and then a long time
and i don't think and people oh my [ __ ]
is tender
okay hold on no because some people will
go you know people are made differently
so it's
for example if you go in a hot tub for
like 20 minutes and you come out and
they test your store and say oh they're
all happy their swimming is good
and then maybe i go in for five minutes
and then now they're like hey man
they're sleeping
they're tired how long are you in there
well no not at what
maybe i don't know like maybe 20 25
minutes
that's kind of long that's really long
but but
but on average seven minutes that i
would like
but then because of uh the father-in-law
i think
that was the first time that he invited
me to the thing because i was you know
dating my girl
and uh i never i've been to like uh
similar like jim jibong things in
in taiwan and it was just like be like a
gym like like a sauna thing and i i'm
never
i'm really happy with not showing my
penis but i'm comfortable with it
not that i have a normal one but i just
like to be free
right and uh but so the dad but then i
was in there for so long and i wanted to
leave but i didn't want to
look like a [ __ ] i wanted bad enough
that time do you respect you for almost
dying
well he didn't know he didn't know but i
still at the end
was like hey do you like some would you
like some water mr joe
and he's like okay like kind of like
because oh you need water yeah you need
water
yeah so then but when i i couldn't see
for
like uh good tension it's not worth it
bro i didn't know where i was going but
do you did you get do you give
because i did the same thing with my dad
i don't care like
if i have to get out i have to get i'll
give a [ __ ] with somebody but i want him
to like me i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] okay i don't
care yeah
that's my balls is that a thing i i
think that's for people who
you're a very respectful man i'm
respectful too yeah but i don't want to
be though
i want to be this way i would get up and
then he would see my hot ball sack from
my
and he was like you see what you did
look at they're touching my kneecaps
they're so hot what are you doing 20
minutes dude you couldn't get up first
you're not gonna i mean i guess he
probably thought oh very respectful
yeah i wanted to because it was the
first time and it's like
he or she doesn't respect your stand-up
comics i know your daughter's working
you're done dude just [ __ ] get out
and then bring him water and scrub his
back
i know but every time i go back you know
to visit them i i get um i'm like damn
it i just want to be
i think there's a lot of pressure of
course it's like um yeah
like of course he's like you know
because i also it's their daughter
you know they wanted her to be okay and
um i also wanted to you know
make let let them be proud but and now
this is like
two weeks ago i told my dad um i
did a zoom thing with like this manager
in taiwan like a really big manager
and uh after he's like hey man i was
like that's really cool right and he's
like
yeah but you know your friend who got
you the thing she has like more
subscribers
and i was like really sad okay i mean
well you know social media stuff is
different from doing real comedy though
you know social media is a whole
different game you have to do you know
very shitty
shitty skits and you know attack a
different crowd
like the the the social media crowd's a
lot younger
so you have to do very obvious jokes
low-hanging fruit jokes and that's what
gets popular
so it's a different game like i'm not
[ __ ] on people who do that you have
to do it right but you're a stand-up
comic it's a different world
but i but that's the thing like you
asked earlier uh what my pla
like my goal is yeah i do want to do
youtube but i don't
do instagram i like do instagram
instagram is way better
oh okay because you're youtube for
stand-up comics i don't suggest it
instagram instagram gets shared more
oh okay yeah same thing with like
tick-tock too like
do those stuff instead of youtube
youtube i have this platform and it's
for the podcast
but i stopped making content on here
except for this stuff because this is
what i enjoy
but if i if if you're trying to gain
like a following
stick to instagram just to do stand up
yeah yeah do stand up and do instagram
and then do these jokes sketches or
whatever you want and make people laugh
that way too
okay yeah and then that's that's how it
really works
right because at the end of the day if
it's just
the the notoriety of people knowing who
you are
that's not getting you through these
certain doors that's an easy fix bro
that's a super easy fix if you're a
funny guy just be funny on your
instagram
oh okay that's really about it i got it
yeah so like just
it's everything's a business instagram
used to be a spot where you could just
put up whatever now people want content
on instagram
which i didn't know that's what it was
for originally it was just for you to
catch up with your friends
through visual picks for through
pictures yeah yeah just just share
it's not like that anymore it's a
business wow you got to run it like a
[ __ ] business there's a lot of kids
now who figure that out
and they're doing you know their jokes
here but their stand-up is bad so you
just have it the other way around when
your stand-up is good
now you got to figure out what's what
they're doing right and do what they do
yeah you could do both why the [ __ ] not
yeah you know so so your goal is to to
i just because i love stand up yeah to
just do uh get a follow so i could do
stand up
i love it i mean you don't really post
much on your instagram because i'm get
really insecure about my [ __ ]
and then sometimes you know you do a
joke like you said like your old stuff
you're like i don't know if i like this
and then sometimes you have a tag and
then it's the same thing like i'll post
the thing i'm like
oh [ __ ] i don't know i just post myself
naked and people seem to love it
that's all i do yeah i'm just getting my
dicks out yeah and people are like
yeah which i enjoy i literally enjoy it
yeah well
people already like your fans you have
fans yeah i mean like even growing my
instagram following like
in the pandemic i grew it like 100k but
oh wow but it was exhausting
you know because i you know i did these
rants that i used to do on youtube but i
started doing it on instagram
that's cool that's interesting that
you're i didn't
i feel like i thought you when you hit a
level you're just like oh well i'm i'm
fine like i'll just post what the [ __ ] i
want but i didn't know that you were
actively
also i wasn't actively trying to grow
the following but i know what people
like
uh you know like i now it's to the point
where i literally just do whatever and
if i grow i grow oh but
like if if if i i can give somebody
advice on how to grow their following
though
because i understand how the system
works you know so i could teach somebody
like i literally have somebody right now
that i
mentored and helped this person grow
their following and now they make a
living off of off of social media
wow because they wanted to do this so i
i helped them since day one and they're
doing pretty well right now
oh wow yeah so it's like it's possible
it's just for me now
i'm in a different space i have i have
this ability to do what i want and i
have people who [ __ ] with me heavy like
the people on this podcast who i [ __ ]
appreciate
and these are the people i care about
now i don't care about if somebody's new
who wants to come into my world thank
you but i'm not going to beg for it
like i just going to do what i do and if
i if i
if i stop being this podcast or i stop
doing i'm okay with it
i could do whatever i want to be happy
yeah i'll
nobody knows me tomorrow who the [ __ ]
cares yeah that's life i don't give a
[ __ ]
i've been doing this since i was [ __ ]
16 i'm [ __ ] 33 now i don't give a
[ __ ] this is a long career i've had
yeah a very long career most people
don't last this long
yeah so if tomorrow nobody knows who i
am i had my fun
yeah i did what i did i've i've i've
done the deed
your to-do list exactly my to-do list is
done dude i just didn't get married
what's the next thing
you just got to give me but why aren't
you doing that yeah
why'd you do it yes hey okay
we just have to get the paperwork done
okay cool yeah and then haven't gotten
that done yet yeah
now i just feel like you're talking to
me right back to me oh you haven't done
[ __ ]
but i um now it's just uh i'm working on
the food stuff in this podcast
yeah and i i didn't think that this
podcast was gonna do as well as it did
uh because i was doing it for myself so
when people are expecting this to come
up every sunday
and it doesn't get like hundreds of
thousands of views you know
like the podcast maybe gets 3040k on the
video side and another like 30 40k on
the audio side
and that's good for me yeah you know
when people wait for this podcast every
sunday
and it makes me happy oh you put it out
every sunday every sunday and every
thursday
i do two podcasts per week you know i
should have just done one
and i'm drowning a little bit so why you
just don't have time to do it
you know what it is it's why'd you do
two then i i don't know
i don't know i just overachieve her oh
you do one
i do two i saw i did two and i was like
there's a lot of work
then i'm exhausted and people like we
heard this story i was like are you too
weak
i have to tell the same stories what do
you want from me and it's pandemic i
have no new stories
this is all i have i had to go to
therapy to find new stories so they dig
things out of my memory yeah
do you actually dude yeah like like you
go through therapy they start bringing
up [ __ ]
that you never thought about but it's so
nice to know it though yeah it's like
this is the thing
i could say on the podcast dude i got
[ __ ] i got i had butt sex when i was
a kid
i didn't do that i was like i'm telling
all this stuff
no yeah but that's the cool thing too i
get to explore these new thoughts and
everything else but
literally just traveling and meeting new
people
you get new stories and i miss that
because pandemic it ruined like half my
jokes
yeah because i love observing people and
then experiencing new things and doing
dumb [ __ ]
like recently i i don't know if i told
this yet but i was
bro have you seen the movie i am sam no
dude one of the saddest [ __ ] films
i've ever seen in my life is about
is sean penn he's uh an adult with
autism that has a genius child gave
birth to a kid and that kid was
abandoned by their mother
and so he starts to go through a custody
battle with like foster care to keep
this child around it's dakota fanning
you know genius child child action every
time i watch that film
i ball out of my mind how many times do
you watch it by [ __ ] 50 times
oh my god yeah so whenever i want to
feel like you and be sad i just i just
watched it but i was on the plane
and i forgot that when you're in
elevation alcohol hits you harder
oh yeah i did it i forgot and so i
ordered three mixed drinks which is like
my buzz limit
let me tell you something i got
plastered and i didn't know what was
going on i i thought i was roofied and
she said blacking out yeah and i was in
first class i never get first class
so you can't even enjoy first last i
[ __ ] embarrassed myself in first
class
because i'm sitting here number one
here's here's a lot of pressure if
you're poor and you go to first class
there's things that first-class people
do like what
like they know that you get free stuff i
don't know this stuff oh
so like when you're a first class in
hawaiian air they give you an ipad to
watch
to watch movies what right and then i
fell asleep during the time they were
passing out the ipad i was so
embarrassed
i just watched it on my phone
i wanted to act like i knew i was
supposed to get the ipad
but but you didn't get one i know but i
didn't want them to know that i was poor
just so i i just i was like oh
oh i know i could get an ipad i just
choose not to but i was too embarrassed
so so i just i just watched this movie
through my phone that was dying
then everybody everybody just yeah this
huge ipad i've been first class but i'm
over here like an economy [ __ ]
just wait but i don't understand why if
you just be like hey can i get my ipad
or did you not know to ask
i have anxiety okay i don't want them to
know
no what i don't know
i don't know i would cut this part out
but you're the most confident anxiety
person that i know
this is all so alive nobody that i know
that
i could tell somebody to go [ __ ] off
face to face but i can't ask for ipad
because i want them to know that i
belong here oh i belong i'm so
i'm so good i belong here wait wait but
it's still checking out that
if if you ask hey can i get my ipad
they're not going to be like you don't
belong here
oh here's your eye you don't know what
goes on in my head oh what does it go on
i'm kidding
i just i just i don't know
so i'm sitting here what just
you just made up a thing and you're like
oh i don't know
okay so what i just
[Laughter]
and you could tell the person next to me
is kind of like would you just get an
ipad bro
but i'm trying to act like yo i couldn't
get it oh i got it i got no i couldn't
get it
but i do watch this oh i got it i just
got it i chose it cool i'm just signing
you know
[ __ ] i'm so i'm just sitting here
with this ipad
and then i'm [ __ ] plastered drunk at
this point right
i didn't know and i'm like yo what's
going on like i'm using all your drugs
too
i'm drunk i didn't know but i'm watching
i am sam yeah and normally when i'm in a
i'm not trying to cry
right yeah nobody makes you cry i was
i'm not even [ __ ] lying this is the
truth i was loud
sobbing because i was so drunk
yeah i can't tell the story yet but i
was i was when i was going to hawaii
recently
yeah i was but you had
no use but you have headphones on so you
don't know you're crying like this so
i'm just
no you didn't i'm plastered bro
i didn't realize how loud i was crying
until my uh bose earbuds right
they battery died and so i just started
just though and then i i i was playing
just listening to it kind of not loud
enough yeah that's where i could hear
the audio
yeah i started crying oh my god was i
doing this for [ __ ] an
hour i started loud crying at this point
i'm too plastered and
the [ __ ] stewardess comes up to me
and she goes do you do you
she's like are you okay sir and i
literally just went i just waited
why because i was crying so much this is
not coming out and this is covered
nobody wants to see [ __ ] tears and
liquid come out of the asian person's
face
right and this dude next to me is slowly
inching away oh
no like this way and i'm looking at the
[ __ ] boogers coming down [ __ ]
his worst nightmare yeah and not i'm
mortified i will never go back on
hawaiian air oh my god
were you wiping it huh i had to wipe it
on my shirt i had no i
oh my god you are sure i was too
embarrassed to ask for napkins
dude what chase no you wore this
i was i was too embarrassed to ask for
napkins why because i didn't want people
to know that i i needed napkins i don't
know
so i just started wiping it on myself
i'm not i'm not [ __ ] kidding you
why and then when i'm okay because i
don't need the napkins
i choose not to do that i'm in first
class it gets worse
it gets worse i'm so ashamed of you
my boxing thing ain't [ __ ] you [ __ ]
did hold on it gets worse
so i now i'm in the inside aisle
right and i have to walk past this
person i have booger hands and booger
face oh no right and i'm looking i was
like
sir can i get up and use this bathroom
yeah i'm so [ __ ] drunk
i'm wobb i i start zigzagging and
touching all the [ __ ] chairs
bro bro don't worry i'm just like in
first class
and i'm so mad at myself i'm like
balance you [ __ ] fat [ __ ] just
balance i'm saying this in my head
and i'm touching all the chair
and i go all the way into the [ __ ]
bathroom i'm so
[ __ ] drunk i'm literally talking to
myself like like eminem in the bathroom
like just just [ __ ] don't lose
yourself for a moment like just [ __ ]
yeah get focused people know that you're
drunk but just if you walk out and
you're fine and it's your
you're okay but i was in the bathroom
for like 10 minutes talking to myself
wow cause i couldn't sober up yeah i
peed i peed
everywhere bro oh man it just i peed
all over the toilet because i couldn't
balance so in there i'm just [ __ ]
trying to wipe all the pee away oh my
god i peed everywhere now you got pee on
your hands now i got pee on my hands i'm
washing it
and i'm wiping my face i got pee on my
face i'm drunk i'm just like dude just
[ __ ] focus
these people no you don't belong in
first class is all i'm thinking
like you're better than this i go
outside
doesn't matter i'm drunk i'm [ __ ]
walking touching everybody
you just accept it i just accepted it
and i just i would have did a public
apology
i mean i'm sorry guys i'm drunk nobody
wants to hear from covet boy
so i'm just sitting here and i just
pretend to sleep for the rest of the
flight oh you pretended to sleep yes
for how long for like another like two
hours because i didn't want people to
look at me you pretended yes
dude that that's such a long time ago it
was a very long time to pretend like oh
my god
because like my head was pounding so i
couldn't sleep because because of the
[ __ ] alcohol
oh my god that that's like the longest
flight i'm supposed to enjoy first class
it was one of the worst experiences of
my life i'm never doing first class ever
again dude oh man they know i don't
belong
you got to do it you got to do it until
yeah you have to watch i am sam dude if
you don't cry watching
sam you're heartless dude it's it's it's
[ __ ] sad
sean penn did an amazing job he got a
lot of criticism because of that they
were
they're being pandering towards people
with mental disabilities but i was just
amazed at his acting it was really great
but that's probably one of the 30 most
embarrassing moments of my life
because of my anxiety yeah i have
[ __ ] social anxiety but is that why
you
drink the alcohol that's where you do
three no three gets me buzzed normally
okay gotcha like i like because
it'll mellow you out and then help you
fall asleep no but the anxiety goes i
gotta do with nothing we talk about
that has nothing to do with you well the
social
well that was just because i was drunk
yeah the social anxiety part where i
couldn't [ __ ] ask for this ipad
oh yeah that's [ __ ] it was just so
tissue though i don't know man
listen as i say this out loud i start to
hate myself do you understand
what's happening here this is this is my
life oh okay i hate this
i have things like that too but yeah but
that's it
hey somebody threatened you in class and
you wondered why you got your ass beat
you're no better than me that's true i'm
sharing this so you know you don't
[ __ ] make fun of me i'm sharing a
very important part of my life with you
well your [ __ ] is way worse
i'm kidding i [ __ ] forgot i was
supposed to bring this up in the last
podcast but that [ __ ]
is one of the worst experiences of my
life that's so funny the um
i feel the same way with like fancy
restaurants i get so uncomfortable
dude i can't i don't i don't want to go
unless like you know some stuff and you
just order
i don't want to be there i don't want to
know why it makes it so because i know
it's like i don't belong there for sure
let me tell you this other embarrassing
story dude like
when i first came to la i met up with
this dude named george he was the
he was the founder of a company called
full screen
full screen was sold for like a
bajillion dollars he made something
he became balling from it right yeah but
this is our first meeting
i don't belong in fantasy [ __ ] i'm poor
clearly you know from this flight
it's been years now and i still don't
understand how to behave in very nice
areas yeah because i always feel like
i'm sticking out like a sore thumb
well i was having a meeting with them
because they wanted to sign me
as uh as an artist to their mcn i was
there was two people they signed first
it was me and adam corolla
and i was one of them i go there
and this is at this fancy ass hotel it's
like the ritz carlton or some [ __ ] it's
like in santa monica earth or something
really fancy hotel i'm amazed i'm a poor
boy yeah i don't know
what do you act like it or you just try
to blend in oh so this is the worst part
okay
right are you dressed up no i was i know
exactly what i was wearing
okay it was you picked it out for this
thing yeah i was like i gotta wear my
nice clothes i got to wear some jordan
shoes
so [ __ ] you know this bright blue shirt
with this with this pea coat which is
like hood
hood nice right yeah and i'm walking up
and then these people are opening doors
for me and [ __ ] and i'm like hey bro
don't open my door from my god
you said that yeah like in my mind i'm
like
don't i open the door because this is
their job i don't know i don't know
these things dude i'm talking about i've
never been in these type of experiences
but you know that
you know that you know somebody opened
the door for you you just you know but
then that's
i just didn't want him to open house i
could open my own door you don't have to
open that yeah for me but he's like
don't do that because i this is my job
yeah you know but then
i uh i remember i go into the bathroom
me and my manager we both go into the
bathroom
and there was this dude standing there
just standing in the bathroom and i'm
like looking at this guy i'm like i look
at him i'm like
hey what the [ __ ] are you doing here bro
he's like looking at me like i'm stupid
he's just out there to hand out towels
but i'm so poor i didn't know that this
is what people do so i thought he was
just some [ __ ] pervert in the
bathroom
just sitting there i'm like [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] are you doing here and then my
manager's like hey bro that he's a towel
guy like he just
so you're just giving him eyes he's
giving him [ __ ] yeah i don't know what's
going on he's not prepping me for
this for this [ __ ] yeah and i'm just
like amazed yeah like this this is these
the nicest paper towels i've ever used
in my life
and i just kept talking about the paper
towels i was like this is really thick
it's not the one that rolls and it
smells recycled paper yeah it feels like
cloth
and i'm just taking this and putting it
into my pocket because it's so nice
this guy's watching me it's so this is
this is i'm poor and that's what poor
people do like this is free [ __ ]
yeah and they're asking me what type of
soap i want whatever i'm like dude
what the [ __ ] is this they're giving me
options
and at this point now i'm like okay this
is a fancy area you're in a business
meeting
these people can't know you're poor like
you cannot even though you showed up to
a nice meeting dressed like a piece of
[ __ ]
but i'm like this is by choice
everything is by choice
so i sit down and he goes oh so i
ordered something for us i ordered a
charcuterie board
at this moment i don't know what a
charcuterie board is
yeah wait wow i'm is this real is this
for real
i'm for real bro like i don't know what
a shark this was like 10 years ago
oh 10 years ago okay yeah this is like
10 10 11 years yeah i don't know what
that was either yeah i don't know what a
shark
report is but he's over here saying [ __ ]
like french has words
yo [ __ ] this french [ __ ] dude you don't
think i know what a charcuterie report
is and you know what i say he goes
you because i ordered a shark korean
board i was like i love it
i love it i love it i love i love
charcuterie
it's my it's my favorite it's my
favorite thing i've never had it i i eat
it all the time
breakfast lunch dinner this is what i do
i'm [ __ ]
just the most [ __ ] i'm the biggest
loser ever
and i i don't do this now but this is a
young right bullshitting
charcuterie i've had it yesterday yeah
it comes out it's like meat cheeses jams
and fruits
right and i'm like this is a lunchable
right and i'm sitting here and i'm he
goes oh dig in
but i'm so embarrassed i don't know how
to eat this so i'm sitting there just
like
oh you you you go at first so i want to
observe him yeah
making it the same thing so we're going
back he goes no you first and i'm like
nah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you first because i don't
know how to eat this [ __ ]
but i won't tell him because of my pride
that i don't know what a charcuterie
board is yeah so i'm sitting here trying
to just we're going back and forth
you first know you first yeah in my mind
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] just
[ __ ] eat it so i know how to eat it
yeah so i get it he wins i'm like cool
i take it and i start making a lunchable
that's cool though i think two crackers
and i stack it up like this
thick this guy's watching you got two
crackers i got two crackers
i started making them you're gonna say
[ __ ]
sandwich god damn it that's why i don't
want to go first
that's so i'd be over here he doesn't
know though and i'm fat as [ __ ]
so how how terrible is it that this fat
[ __ ] is over here making the thickest
[ __ ] salami sandwich he's ever seen
in his
life and he's just staring at me like
who is this barbarian yeah i'm like
charcuterie
i know this thing and then i see him and
then after i eat my thing this sandwich
that's like three inches thick
i'm eating it right yeah and i see him
make it he just puts one piece of cheese
and one salami and i was like you
[ __ ]
idiot why did you make a lunchable
i was mortified a dog i was so
embarrassed i was like this [ __ ]
couldn't have just made this stupid
sandwich dude i was
so [ __ ] mad oh my god but that's what
it's like
a comic that lives with anxiety this is
my life i keep doing stuff that i don't
have to be in
yeah i hate it yeah that's so funny
that's why i take cbd all the time
because i have anxiety yeah
i have to like learn how to chill that
[ __ ] really helps though the cbd it
helps me so but you guys you got up to
those too
oh i do it intermittently i do it every
day oh great yeah like when uh
because now i'm able to address my
anxiety where it's like hey you're being
unreasonable relax
mine is the plain thing sometimes things
gets a little crazy
you know i i just i might have to cut
that out
i don't know that's hilarious that's my
life though like this literally happens
like
like i [ __ ] you not my my [ __ ] luck
with things partially because of my
behavior
and just things just happen to me all
the time yeah and so
things just happen to you all the time
it does dude like bro i was in hawaii
once
yeah this is also something embarrassing
that happened yeah like i'm very loud
i'm very boisterous right
i don't know how i didn't i don't know
what happened this day
but my camera broke i got a surfboard to
the face
and then for some [ __ ] reason the
same day all my friends saw this [ __ ]
really embarrassing i thought the window
was open and i wanted to peek my head
out when i was reversing the car to see
if there was another car on the side
yeah window was up and i face planted
right into a into a rolled up window
and i'll see my nose pressed up against
it everybody saw it i wanted to die
yeah one of the dumbest things and you
think you're dumb you think you're dumb
and smart
i put my face through a rolled up window
wait
i i wait i don't i don't really get it
you don't have to
i for some i thought the window was down
and i wanted to see if i had enough
space
on the side when i was backing out right
because because people were blocking
myself so your window was down no it was
up i thought it was down oh
you just you just saw yourself and i
smashed my face into a [ __ ]
window like a [ __ ] bird when was it
when was this this was like
went through hawaii seven years ago yeah
this is a long time ago but you don't do
that now though
maybe who knows there's a lot of bad but
yeah but the airplane thing happened
actually it's hilarious this is my life
man oh man
yeah i've been laughing like that in a
while that was really nice hey
thank you well thank you for laughing at
me and allowing me to share this story
with you
okay yeah wow that wraps up this podcast
everybody
hey check out jason cheney not to be
confused
with a little cross-side [ __ ] jason chen
he's my friend by the way that's why
this is why i talk to him like this
i love jason chen i'm a little [ __ ] but
check out jason cheney what's your
what's your instagram
jason cheney n j-a-s-o-n-c-h-e-n-y
just straight up that yes cool check out
james and cheney check him on his
instagram look out for his stand-up
shows i'm telling you this guy's the one
i'm gonna put i want you to come back
again with pat's on here and then we'll
just we'll just chop it up again i want
you to return dude yeah
thank you so much do hell yeah so genius
brain podcast every thursday sunday
we'll see you all next time
peace